Jonnelle, thank you so
much for making time
to chat with us about the Fed.
This year in 2022,
the Fed has rapidly
increased its benchmark rate
which is a 15-year-high.
Talk about the different ways
ordinary people like me
are impacted by the Fed's
interest rate hikes.
As they raise interest rates,
the goal is really to
make it more expensive
to borrow money.
So of course we're feeling it
in the housing market already.
Mortgage rates went up
even before they actually did
the first rate increase.
But it does trickle down
to other kinds of loans.
The goal is to lower demand.
And that cooler demand should
in the end lead to lower prices.
The Fed spends so much time
looking at economic forecasts
to suss out whether or not they
are making the right calls.
Do those indicators
actually give them a good picture of how
our economy is doing? economy is doing?
We know that the Fed rely
a lot on its forecasts.
Because of the pandemic and the
unusual circumstances that we are in,
a lot of those forecasts were wrong.
So what we hearing from officials now
is that they are going to be
looking more closely at
what is the economy doing.
Spending, home prices, inflation, hiring
and even some of these more
high frequency indicators,
how many people
are making reservations.
One of the things the
Fed is working towards
is achieving this idea of a soft landing.
Can you talk about what that is
and how it's different
from a hard landing.
The goal for the Fed is
to bring inflation down
while minimizing the pain that we
would feel in our everyday lives.
So they define that as like trying
to accomplish cooling inflation
without leading to a
spike in unemployment.
Or at least limiting it
to a moderate increase.
As we head into 2023,
what do we know about what the
Fed's terminal rate could look like?
Just how high are these interest rates
supposed to get?
Fed officials are saying that
it's really uncertain at the moment.
And that it will depend on
what happens with inflation.
If inflation starts to
come down more quickly,
then rates don't have to go as high.
If it takes a while,
they have to go higher.
Right now, the markets think
the rates will peak at
Some people think it could be
a little bit higher than that.
But we'll see.
Only time will tell
and it will depend on inflation
and how much shift we see in the economy.